what's going on there reject nation greg
johnny coy here we're about to watch miss
marvel the first episode he and you love miss
love miss marvel you've read like all the comics
every single issue i think she's the modern day
silver age spider-man i think she has a lot of
those parallels we'll talk about that after
the episode and she represents you culturally
i mean when i think about me i think young muslim
american woman from new jersey very much those
things fortunate enough to get to watch this
early but the background's a little different
than it has been lately because uh i i've moved
look we've traveled through the quantum realm
isn't that fascinating very minimalist
comparatively guys uh full length watch
longer secret with the time code available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon page cover
bunch of shows over there exclusively reaction
highlights included at the same tier thank you
guys for shower support also if you can't join
us on our patreon leave a like in your thoughts
down below in the episode helps us out of the
algorithm yay youtube algorithm they're the
best and subscribe click that notification
bell get notified when our next reaction
for uh miss marvel is up and while you're at
if you've got some downtime go check out koi's
comic corner which i'm hoping is a successful
weekly segment or bi-weekly segment by this point
uploading this video then boys at where john
prepper thank you so much for editing down
these highlights for making us look good and
hey if you guys need some editing help hit
them up but just wait until they're done cutting
our stuff yeah we come first always narcissus
the final chapter to my temper series
on earth's mightiest hero captain marvel
alien ships invading fans being a jerk about
magical stones our heroes were done for until
i know some of you think well she abandoned
the people of earth but like look it's not true
maybe we'll learn something new at
avenger con this week avenger con
interesting anyway that's all i got
for this week next week i'm going to
kick off a special two-part series on
why i think thor is secretly a gamer
kamala please don't forget to look at
the mirrors every 15 seconds that these
turns oh kamala my kamala the road is a long and
winding one so never fully stop it stop sight
just make sure that the instructor can see you
move your head and remember to say bismillah
before you start the car you're gonna need all
the help you can get don't even have a license
it's very very echo right bless you
i'm not coming anyone's thought
oh come on are you trying to tell
me she didn't look in the mirrors
often enough for you and your
clipboard camina give me my keys
okay kamala come least they look after this is
my fault this is all my fault for my genetics
there's some fun little artisan writer easter
eggs on that are you inviting me over to play
smash bros because if so i'm i'm busy don't
hate the player hate the game the thing is i do
hate the game hate the big glove sorry zoe fine
i like your jacket thanks i like your necklace uh
thanks it's actually my name in arabic
while concrete please come to my office asap
you've done something very wrong i'm just kidding
it's crazy that the whole school's been here
they're telling me you're doodling
all day staring off into space
in your little fantasy lounge hey oh really
we truly started the meeting 30 seconds ago
you got to be with me girl mr wilson was my
father my name is gabe his name was also gabe so
time to start really thinking about your future i
mean college admissions are coming up before you
know it it's sats it's essays it's application
man that normal [__] is boring in the marvel
world it's interesting that you have to make it
approachable but it's also like we're watching a
girl in high school i see a girl divided is she
there is she there where's kamala and i know i
know fantasy's fun fantasy is really fun but right
now i need you to pull yourself together and join
reality how does it feel certain stop it's a
very interestingly constructed shot just there
it reminded me of rules of attraction but in
reverse this is the first one ever right and then
future historians they're going to start writing
about this year of adventure condom where does
it start here okay it's not going to be another
first avenger calling ever again never i really
like her performance a lot she's very natural
so natural and just like every single thing i
love she seems to hate and it's it's like she
thinks i'm some kind of you know weirdo you are
a world but more importantly i've gotten weirdly
good at airbrushing flirts like you about comics
with skills like airbrushing it's not to like
works i am sure it was a compliment thank you
okay i can't build you a horse but
otherwise you could build me slap baby wings
you know that's very neat completely you
wings little tiara captain princess no
princess i'm sorry but you know what's even
better what zombie captain marvel i could be like
this is so cool okay hey let's never
do that zombie impersonation again
wowie so it's like
watching the movie that inspired the
show i thought that was an old woman
i didn't recognize that's my kid is michael sarah
you know michael sarah can play allen the
fourth golden girl michael sarah ahmed have
you lost your years this is so cool is this
nannies that is jump oh she knows what that is
what happened she decided that
she wasn't ready for commitment
so now she's off gallivanting
through europe to discover herself
good for her i mean she wanted to
travel the world and she went for it
she's trouble with this one she's going to
discover that she doesn't have a ring on her
finger that's what she's going to discover
that's what matters most yeah absolutely
so this is a security camera okay so
you can see who's home from your phone
from my phone oh yeah from the
phone we're living in the future
zoo zoo turn off the lights
are you staying for dinner no no i got some work
okay i'll pack you something to go no no i'm good
no no of course i will did you ask her
about adventure god come on ask her just
ask her no there's a spicy one at the bottom
do that so fast you stick to the
gizmos beta this is my secret
superpower so there's this thing called
avengercon fan events celebrating our great
heroes of our time and bruno's um he's
like really into this stuff you know so
he really wants to go and um wow is this a
joke no is bruno recording this for internet
look i promise i won't do anything
stupid you you do trust me right
no i don't trust you how exactly
will you be dressed huh cat
please please and but me no because i can't do a
single normal teenage thing in this house right
you're not normal
you know all she does to me say no it's like
where is this out of proportion worry for you i'll
talk to them yeah i mean you look kind of but yeah
i love how much there's a purple aesthetic to this
show i it's like one of the like this and moon
knight i think the most uniquely formatted like
that felt like just an error and this feels like
whoever directed it it's so stylized yeah it's a
really nice visual language great color palette
and like this circle cue and like all
the visuals are right from the books
totally yeah they totally read koi well like
circle q is kind of like the daily bugle like it's
it's it's part of the dna of the comics so it's
really cool to see them like focus on it exactly
yes i'm glad you're finally picking up on that
who did carol danvers pose for where did
they get that photo artist reenactment
we have decided to let you go your abu will drive
you there and he will go inside with you for two
hours and as far as your dressing goes i have a
surprise please war machine oh the hulk oh my god
no it's amazing there's no big hulk
little hulk it's not at all this is
mine and bruno's thing okay come on buddy
can't wear shortcomings to avenger con okay
and and you can't come with me not just like that
because it is so humiliating dude he's cosplaying
he looks great if you don't go with
your dad you're not going at home
you're not going to dress up like all those
other girls in skimpy outfits that is not you
so kamala kills her mom in
the comics right yep okay
no power and then he hulks out
they're villains they're not going
damn it you lost your ally a lot of this strangely
reminds me of my filipino culture side stressing
out this captain marvel's weird no it's not and
it's childish and i know that okay and and let's
be honest it's not really the brown girls from
jersey city who saved the world sure they do
you're kamala khan you want to save the
world then you're gonna save them all
are you imagining this with the red equipment
god you made these yeah do you like them yes
oh bruno corelli corporation i like it has a nice
ring to it how do they turn on right here wow
she just seems like such a real girl i know i
keep i keep getting lost in like she seems so real
time to go full carry please switch the tv kamala
please tell bruno the zuzu
is possessed by the evil gina
switch it on if i can't leave the house to go to
avenger con i'll go to adventure
come without leaving the house
this is the plan kamala you're the best sister
ever honestly you should have been an only child
5 55 i suit up in the greatest
captain marvel costume the earth
has ever seen and like then i
make my way out of the house
undetected but extremely impressive
you will be waiting in your country
but what if your parents go into your
room so when there's a knock on the door
finally you being a genius is coming in handy
what do you mean finally catch the bus to
camp lehigh it might be a tight window but
we're going to do it with styles wait is
that a spiking off a bridge onto a bus
then it's time for a tight but spontaneous
60 minutes of fun at avengercon
cosplay competition i win obviously collect my
crown i'm assuming it's made of real diamonds
i'll sneak back into my room just
before my dad comes in at 9 22
pm that's the plan so your plan is take the bus
you know what she seems up with captain
marvel in the future is gonna be pretty sweet
nope
you're doing good kamala
oh my goodness
ow oh that was my way back in no we missed the bus
we can still make the next one
but if we miss it it's game over
of
you course the infinity stones on the spokes
i wish we did conventions out
here that celebrated superheroes
like san diego would be a
good spot or woodland hills
woodland hills con let's go
the song was great thanks oh my god smashed
somewhere any rock stars
heads are exploding right now
pause everything is that an early she-hulk or a
black widow i couldn't tell i think it was gamora
definitely
america
wow it's becoming the boys monetizing
our superheroes hey drax costumes cool
asgard pride for valkyrts that's good
no
destroy her why is she here the costume's not even
accurate she doesn't even like the avengers i know
it's okay it's okay okay i think that's a great
costume you have the gloves yeah they're in my bag
let's straighten that out come on it's a contest
last call for the captain marvel cosplay
competition cosplayers please line up on the
side of the stage no no give it up amazing captain
america cosplayers thank you cosplayers smashed
the details in the background are fantastic i
can't get it on it's like still for some reason
where are the gloves okay just
crap i left it in the bathroom
but he made the gloves dude fine you
got the bangle put it on just jam it on
pakistani bengals bite
wow
i got chills
oh damn she just goes like full center stage
oh my god kamala what have you
done he's gonna kill everyone
she's gotta win she's gotta
win she's gotta win now yep
oh no big hand and biggin oh
that's not that big a deal just sprinklers
oh people are dying i don't know
what are you available to book for
parties do you want to take a picture
i'll tag you i fall back mostly
oh my god they just killed zoey
wait are you available for parties or
not just happened what just happened i
don't even know what to say i can't
believe it i actually have powers
it's amazing
don't stop okay i'd never sell anyone
never ever never ever ever really really there's
some great camera work in this show ah [__] whoa
yep who is this rebellious girl sneaking
out do you want to be good or or do you
want to be some you know this cosmic head in
the clouds person both you think about that
i remember giving that same speech to koi yeah
i didn't take it well yeah i stopped
sneaking out for avengers cons though
most of the art in the background is comic
authentic and there's a terry dodson piece
they keep using that's great that's exactly what
we talked about good job remembering those details
cosmic she's made a choice
oh that's right the guys who did bad
boys three right yeah i'd forgotten that
that's a normal statue of liberty yeah new york
not the cap statue of liberty oh that's true
well it fell yeah i noticed that it's regular
wayne street that's a oh hey batman's
family dude comic books are all connected
a cosplayer with too much time on their hands
not this one i've never seen powers like that
yeah bring her in oh kamala's law is coming
kamala's law is coming she's
going to need a good lawyer
daredevil is going to be at all the shots
very good lawyers catching bricks through many
windows originally there are snow globes where
they return them into bricks and posts you guys
know that yeah because of the shape of his hand
and all that stuff can you believe white people
wrote and directed that whoa what really yeah
i thought i thought the brothers that directed
i don't know i don't know they were pure white
didn't you catch their names samuel and william
i don't judge my names my name's coy whiteman
we are all white men except for you that was very
charming that was i i'm really impressed uh i will
say it's we're not reviewing it yet credits we
gotta fade a little little wipe here to let the
audience know if this that's divided watching the
credit section's different john wipe it white hey
look we got fancy dancy mics we're not gonna talk
for too long though that's what i always say yeah
absolutely won't talk for too long he's always
wrongly talked for too long is that right koi
anyway i was really charmed by this a lot i think
uh it goes without saying that the visual style
i mean is obviously very it's kind of felt like
a splice of what was that hayley steinfeld movie
edge of seven true grey 17 and uh scott
pilgrim versus the world a little bit of both
but i also did like how committed they were to the
cultural influence what is their exact background
pakistani she's pakistani but she's the first
muslim superhero like to headline up a comic ever
or yeah like i'm not pakistan some people think
i'm from some people think i'm pakistani or
indian or mexican or i'm all kinds of anything but
irish anything but irish is what i get growing up
filipino in california you're surrounded by
a lot of like cultural clashes of wanting to
express yourselves and you know and and go do
your own thing have your own freedom but then
you could feel like kind of the oppressive very
disciplined you have to live by the parents uh
rules because you know it's a lot i'm like a lot
of us out here like first generation you know with
the kamala khan situation so i really identified
with that aspect there are other qualities i'm
sure that you can probably identify with
and koi is just the biggest fan of us
of course the superhero fantasy side of being
obsessed i'm sure he can identify with so i think
there's there's quality because before this before
watching this sometimes you're like it's only just
for kids just for little kids and i don't know
i thought this was actually really charming
i didn't find it hilarious and i wasn't like
swept up in wonder yet i was very very charmed
throughout and there's a lot i really appreciate
i think it's so composed every shot seemed like
it was so purposeful like it seemed like
there was a real shot list of the way this was
executed that it did have me curious what was
the prep like beforehand because they must have
had to storyboard this out like crazy whereas the
other ones i'm sure you have a shot list but maybe
not as storyboarded but this felt like it had to
be just with the amount of integration they had
but uh and and the other main thing too is
uh this iman velani actress holy [__] she's
gonna be able to keep up with everybody she was
fantastic she is so good she's so it feels like
i'm i'm watching like a real kid uh one of those
real nerdy kids out here you know you know marvel
can pull off visuals they can pull up aesthetic
they can pull off a fun tone and whatever but to
capture the essence of this character was the
most impressed i was was with her performance
i couldn't ever everyone's good everyone's so
natural but her especially was like you seem so
real i kept getting that's the thing that i was
getting swept up in the most was how real she
she seemed now it's time to see like the real
dramatic half scenes can she cry on camera that's
the mark of a good actor that's all it really
takes it's crying nikoi i know you're gonna like
hog the mic so much just hold on for a second
john get in there what did you identify with
what did you think point out something
different that i didn't point out go for it
john i really loved this uh first taste of
the show partly because it felt like i some
of the shows feel more like you're watching an
episode of something or like a show and this
felt like i just watched a piece of a movie it was
really really gracefully composed and they have a
lot of setup to do and you're in a familiar world
but i thought that they really really did a nice
job of establishing a tangible and a cultural tone
that feels very alive like iman vilani anchors
everything with just that incredibly natural
charisma but even beyond that just the way in
which they realize new jersey and the convention
and just the time and place of everything
felt like a great convergence of some indie movie
with the marvel cinematic universe flavors and i
love love loved the way they composed everything
from the visuals to the music but but really just
that you know that look in that aura like it's
got great color and it's got really beautiful
striking again composed shots that really
feel like you said intentional i feel like
especially now we're at a point where people are
sort of expecting marvel to upgrade and be more
expressive with their visual palette and their
emotional palate and i think that this speaks
to that whereas certain other things have maybe
you know struggled i felt like this was really
colorful and really beautiful and it uses that
scott pilgrim style animated you know heightened
world to great effect without making me sit here
and go you just got pilgrim you know so so yeah
i i really love it and hey you know yeah white
guy blah blah blah whatever but i totally related
to kamala khan and just the situation she's
in even though it's not my exact experience
i really really felt for her experience and i
did feel for you know the aspects of that that
are universal while so appreciating the aspects
that are very specific to the pakistani culture
and everything else that comes with that and i
just can't wait to see the whole thing expand
all right koi now now what we're missing here
though is this isn't big enough you know how
does this tie into the multiverse in avengers
secret wars talk only about that koi kang
is that you can have a contained story that
feels big and a big story that feels small
screw that koi you're not talking
about the things i wanted bigger coins
is that she's cosmic but arguably one of the
most contained to herself characters in the
mcu well now she's the marvel universe the reason
i love spider-man is because you always feel like
he's a guy that's just trying to get by spider-man
is always late for work he's always trying to make
sure he can undo a messed up date with mj he's
always trying to make sure that he does the right
thing when he feels like he's the wrong guy
he always uses comedy as a defense mechanism
spider-man was invented in the 60s spider-man has
been around for a very long time it has gotten to
the point where it's very hard to retell some of
his stories and there are long periods of time
where spider-man comics are not great because
he's been around for so long what i loved is
that when we got kamala khan in 20 i think she
was in an issue or two of captain marvel in 2013
her title started in 2014. so we've had her for
eight years what i love i don't know google it i
don't i think you're way off but i'm clearly the
70s i'm not going to embarrass you so what i love
is that when we got this character it reminded me
of what it was first like to discover peter parker
spider-man it's it's someone who is in high school
dealing with day-to-day problems in extraordinary
ways it's someone like everyone has a high school
experience so we can identify with that experience
even as you know older dudes but we also can learn
from this character and i love the weird awkward
moments of high school conversation juxtaposing
the moments of pure cosmic power i love that as a
dude especially a white dude from boston i have
very little exposure to pakistani tradition or
to pakistani food or muslim culture and i think
that you can make any comic book educational in
a fun way to either treat you about relationships
morality your world view or specifically cultures
and what i got out of miss marvel and the reason
i think the show was doing such a good job is
it makes you go hey i get seven tenths of
these things i would like to learn more about
the three-tenths i don't without it feeling like
you're an other you're not othering a thing you're
not an outsider you go oh this all makes sense
please teach me this and i think as americans
that's something we other very quickly and i think
it's really problematic how much we like to go hey
what if we do this thing that feels normal all
the time and don't let things progress or learn
and this character it kind of makes you learn and
i really love that the show is giving us a lot of
things that feel familiar while planting seeds to
have us grow with the character and that's what i
got out of the comic book so i love that she has
a small town like spider-man that also has a big
town like jersey city i love that she has the
circle cue like peter has the daily bugle i love
that her family feels like peter's mj harry gwen
i love that her family has the moral compass of
an uncle ben and not may but she has this net of
of comfort while also having the struggle of being
a teenager while also being someone that doesn't
look like everyone else that's just like everyone
else and that i think is going to be so important
for kids nationwide and internationally to feel
seen for the first time while also informing dumb
white dudes that like you know people are people
so i i think the show is doing all the things
i love about the comics and it's doing it in
a stylized way that makes it unique and i love
that what i'm really hoping yeah like where is
when are we going to get off of earth
rambo going to show up in this one
g willow wilson is the writer who brought her
her solo title like so she'd been introduced
but the first solo book which they used to cover
up in there i i love the mr wilson nod there and
i really love that they planted some of that arc
from that first run and again terry dotson one of
my favorite artists is the background piece in
her room that made me happy i what i'm waiting
for is i'm really happy for you corey i'm sure
everyone is marvel everyone listening right now
was like i'm still listening congratulations koi
it's for me you won clearly this show is for me
that's right what what i am hoping for that and
i think the show will eventually go down that
route is this episode captured and i imagine
the rest of the series will be you know kamala
khan's perspective and so with capturing
her at this specific point in her journey
you know she's feeling that a bit of like feeling
oppressed and a lot of it is cultural clashes
i feel like they're planting seeds where it feels
like a true celebration of pakistani culture as
well because i could see that there could be a
different argument to be made with some of the
semi-generic setup because i don't i don't feel
like the execution feels generic i think there's a
lot of great nuance to it that's something that 70
30. i think that's how we felt at the end of the
show i think you have to start in 90 10. yeah
and then you grow it i mean start at the part
where she feels like the oppressed side and can't
be yourself and is having a clash with the culture
and family and and you know all that jazz and
then by the time you get there because like i i
liked the i don't know how it is in the comics
and i'm curious to hear what you think because
i know they changed the power set here to have the
band be part of her family legacy that gives her
the powers like everything she wanted is coming
through something that she that is generational
and i think that in and of itself is honoring
a part even though it's sci-fi and [__]
it's honoring a part of uh the pakistani culture
i imagine it'll eventually lead down that road
so i'm excited to see how it goes there where it
embraces it all you know and i'm imagining that
it'll go down a path for her parents i don't know
if her parents will find out her true identity i
don't know the path that's headed down now i know
the feeling like her mom has some knowledge that
yeah no she they alluded to that that she's like
don't touch those bands you know and as much as
we love her so far like abu is nailing it like
he's so the character of the comics like we love
the brother as you know limited screen time it
does a lot but i i i will say my only negative
is too early to really quantify i love
that she's an inhuman and i love that some
of the body dysmorphia that comes with being a
teenager is kind of representing the detergent
the terrigen myths i assume are not here but when
you talk about the generational influence i would
have had like you know the inhuman element
be part of like maybe her ancestry and maybe
she is an inhuman that this this activates the
the the gene instead of the territories i don't
think they're touching the inhumans i don't think
they're gonna mess with it i thought maybe after
dr strange spoilers for doctor strange you've
seen it two months ago and black bolt i thought
like maybe they were gonna slowly reintroduce the
inhumans by way of like you know that little taste
that that touch of that it would be unlikely now
that we've seen how the power manifests and it
does kind of remind me more of like you know some
of the more cosmic characters there are quantum
bands there are certain bands from the 70s that
not music fans bands uh that tie into you guys
chart in the 60s you guys tried the 60s clearly
but like though so i'm curious if those things
are generational if those things are cultural or
if there's going to be anything that makes her
unique on top of the band that like the band has
to coincide with blankety blank because i do think
it's really important that the terrorism miss
activate something in her and then again the body
dysmorphia like her being an insecure teenager
and then her having like crazy like physical like
almost cronenbergy and scary attributes you don't
get that as much with shiny objects you don't get
that as much with like ooh sparkle cosmic so i
think there needs to be some of that somehow but
it hasn't bothered me enough that it's an overall
negative i know people are gonna be uproarious but
for me it is my negative but i'm not closing
my mind to it i'm optimistic that the reason
they did it is to be seen and the cost of trying
to make stretchy hands look good is prohibitive
that's why john krasinski had 45 minutes of
screen time clearly off camera john i'm curious
as someone who's not said devotee of comics
uh-huh how do you feel about the power set
here without having this pre-existing like
love and meaning but now just introduced fresh
thoughts my thoughts i have this review
much like coy i'm curious about the power setting
and it's a it's an idea like it's it's a shift in
idea and so now i'm sitting here going okay it's
up to them to make something interesting out of
that i think they can i you know i mean i wasn't
expecting her just to have a full-on like power
blast at the you know in a very public setting
in this episode so if anything moved maybe a tad
quick because of the change to me it felt like
that i mean i'm finishing up agents of shield so
that's like prime this is my moment to sit here
and go canonize that you coward so that you can
use tara jin because that's such a huge part of
that show i can imagine that maybe especially if
we do get more cross cosmic universal multiversal
shenanigans factoring in here that maybe
that will tie into why her power is the way it is
but my hope is that it's got something to do with
the origin of that bangle and that maybe there is
uh something akin to like the ancestral plane or
something like that that maybe could explain
it or something that again ties back into
culture because one other thing that struck
me about this is i was reminded of shang chi
in the early moments where you know they're at
home and you're seeing home life and you're just
seeing that side of the culture and then you know
obviously the mcguffin is also tied into that in
some way but in shanghai obviously you leave
home and you don't really come back and you're
mostly doing like cosmic crazy stuff so i feel
like here you've got an opportunity to maintain
the home life across it but also tie that into the
origin of the bangle whatever her mom might know
and maybe make something meaningful and driven for
that so while i am bummed to lose that metaphor of
like yeah this is a physical change happening to
my body that also factors into just how i feel
about myself i could see them making it something
meaningful and i hope that's what they do rather
than just being like it's a cool cosmic mcguffin
takes the end can i have one can i have one last
thought is that okay you are on the thinnest
device let me um let me test shall run by you
know you know what coil yeah yeah you can you can
have it okay thank you for permission i appreciate
it one thing i'm interested in is in the comics
she's one of the champions which is a modern rear
interpretation of a more street level team and
it's really politically charged right now in the
comic books the champions comic is uh more about
global warming and people's rights and refugees
it's a lot more topical than maybe the avengers
because currently the avengers are living in a
celestial's head and they're fighting vampires so
it's not exactly like linear so what i think the
champions do is they allow us as readers to have
a team that feels like it's fighting for what we
might experience in real life while the avengers
do their cosmic stuff but what's interesting is
kamala is always going to feel straight levels
she represents jersey city she represents all
those things what's interesting in the comics now
is they've already had the civil war thing happen
like a decade ago in the comics we had civil
war happen about a decade ago in the movies now
what happens legally in the comic books is when
the civil war which is called the scovie accords
in the uh movies when that doesn't pass when the
scovia courts fail in the comic books years later
those same lawyers and the same like bad guys try
to pass it by way of having people under 18 not
have uh the rights to be superheroes basically
they make it like child labor laws effectively
and they call it kamala's law because kamala
gets really really injured and she's in a coma
so she doesn't have the ability to fight for
herself so people are using her name against
her very friends people are using her name to
persecute people she cares about the fact that
the cop that was trying to get spider-man to mess
up is now in this and the fact that we're getting
a lawyer show right after this and the fact that
daredevil is supposedly in everything for a while
i do think we're gonna see some interesting
follow-ups to civil war and legal ramifications in
this show that set up certain things in the future
like the young avengers which i think is going to
be this universe's champions parallel maybe read
comics i don't think any of that was necessary
why am i even here you took the
words right out of my mouth coy
greg's gonna cut it say save for say for
another time oh my god this is in love with this
what is trending i want this video training kid
who shows up in class and you're like aren't
we supposed to turn in the assignment
i i'm really proud of the assignment
you said we were gonna have a quiz
this week it's friday where's the quiz
i thought we had a quiz it's cause he's trying
to get me to fight eric voss every premiere
if i have one genuine criticism about this
show is i i uh where's the mob rangers no
i took him out where's dj paulie d track
super rose got taken out i hope there's actual
consequences for when she does crazy [__] i mean
they did set up the thing with the cops still felt
like a quirky setup i think it's gonna be a ram i
think that's gonna be consequences i think that's
gonna be the undercurrent it needs to feel truly
consequent because even the stakes in the moment
was just like oh my god all these people in danger
but no one really feels like they're indeed they
all got smacked up like she rolled mjolnir
through her face still just like that's fine
what i'm saying like that was that might have
killed her i could i really see that becoming
a thing where it's like man this footage is
circulating oh she she attacked the thing
but i feel like popular girl is going to come
back and be like no she saved my life and then
that'll yeah that'll be a thing yeah it's not a
heavy criticism it's just more of a curiosity i'd
like to be a commentary in the police state and
like the overwatch of cameras and how we have big
brother that we implement ourselves through social
media that's what i want to see and miss marvel
fun team street level fantasy i'd like to talk
about the fact that ring lights account for more
surveillance than george orwell ever predicted
i want to invest for living in an age of pure
paranoia story about you know cell phone addiction
and pornography addiction and miss marvel i
i don't that's what i yeah let's just
do shame how are you in the marvel
michael fassbender comes back as back teenagers
are in high school probably watching just graphic
imagery on their phones being consumed
and being falsely diagnosed with adhd
that's what i want to see in miss marvel guys
yes take on the pharmaceutical industrial complex
yeah over prescribing things that's right man
we're gonna go there they don't want us that's why
they stamp down supplements and vitamins they
don't want us to prevent disease they just want
to keep us up when they arrest kamala khan we do
it's political policing issues of the industrial
complex that is churning out profits in the prison
system yeah see there's a lot you can do i think
that's episode two and i feel like they are
only scratching the surface right now guys just
getting started greg we're just getting started
hey kids there's a lot to learn see we could
have ended this and now look what look what's
happening thanks for watching guys leave a like
cameron is currently out of commission we got to
get this damn video up but i wanted to shout out
michael b today michael b should have a reaction
up as well for this miss marvel thing and this
guy's been doing such a good job lately he
deserves to be proper shouted out because
he's so good at what he does so if you thought two
white guys reacting to miss marvel wasn't enough
get a third whitey in there before you hop to
blind wave to get four why more people in there
all the crap go to omni media first michael
b michael bay b is what we like to call right
he's become a really great friend of mine
as well um i'm really happy to know you bud
sometimes you text me too much and then i get all
upset when you stop texting me and i'm like what
the hell i just like to be wanted so dude we got
to keep this toxic relationship going it's what's
making us thrive and before you all in your head
no i don't actually think you text me too much
but sometimes you text a little too much again i'm
only joking you don't text me that much that is a
sarcastic comment but seriously you gotta get your
[__] together do you not have any other friends
that's me kidding
i'm not kidding but i am